[Música]
cuando era niña
nunca pensé que me sentiré diferente a
los demás cuando estás en adolescencia
que ibas avanzando que estas razones es
raro los brazos crecen como tentáculos
de pulpo las piernas se ven como si
fueras de súper elástica no hubo ropa
luna que estuviera a mi gusto lo más
interesante es que los pantalones
siempre me quedaron cortos
me veía como un fenómeno la ropa estaba
siempre cortita estaba chiquita y eso me
hacía sentir diferente era un fenómeno
de la naturaleza
lo malo es de que los medios de
comunicación yo podía ver estas
características de notables claramente
que daban el valor de una persona
dependiendo del color de piel inclusive
del color de tus ojos era inaudito en un
patito red era un patito feo lo más
interesante aún fue que me gustaba la
escuela amaba la escuela y esto me hizo
hacer una rezagada social
cuando empecé a estudiar que decidí a
estudiar mi carrera profesional
encontré disciplinas que me ayudaron a
entender de cierta manera por qué nos
comportamos de esta manera porque era mi
pregunta por qué por qué por qué por qué
nos comportamos así que queremos qué
hacemos y que de una u otra manera me
iba a hacer entender las diferencias que
sí existen y finalmente que podemos ser
incluidos
qué es la mercadotécnica de la
publicidad para qué sirven estas dos
disciplinas la mercadotecnia según
philip kotler dice que estudia las
necesidades las carencias y los deseos
de las personas pero qué tiene que ver
con la diferencia la diferencia es de
que como humanos sentimos pertenencia
hacia un objeto hacia un lugar y que nos
ayuda a esto nos agrupamos con
características homogéneas en las cuales
nosotros tenemos este mismo sentido esta
pertenencia
está esta división se reconoce como
segmentación para aquel entonces cuando
yo estaba en la secundaria esta
segmentación eran diferentes grupos pero
estos grupos tenían las mismas
características que quiere decir se
hacía lo mismo para todos como si todos
fuéramos iguales y realmente nombre por
otro lado la publicidad según arenys
estudia pero estudiar y generar no está
persuasión hacia las personas que es
tratar de convencerte de algo tienen
convencerte pero qué pasa entonces
entonces la publicidad es un arma de dos
filos por qué porque de una u otra
manera las marcas están publicitando
quieren que las conozcas es más tienen
que las compres pero para causar en ti
que se refleja que somos una sociedad
denigrada o más que nada somos una
sociedad de migrante bastante
interesante entonces esto porque lo que
es lo que provoca de alguna otra manera
de que tengamos ciertos reflejos que de
alguna u otra manera veamos que la
publicidad crea patrones de conducta
crea ciertas características culturales
y sociales que estamos cumpliendo
desafortunadamente estos efectos de
imagen publicitaria han causado efectos
colaterales por ejemplo aquí se ve
obviamente mis características nunca
coincidieron con los patrones de
conducta
entonces nos podemos hacer una pregunta
interesante que es primero el huevo o la
gallina y qué se refiere con la
publicidad quiere decir que la
publicidad ha reflejado estos
estereotipos culturales y sociales dónde
simplemente al revés y no viceversa
la publicidad se basa en estos
estereotipos o los estereotipos son de
no sé dónde de no sé cuándo y quién los
estableció para poderse cumplir esto
generó como decía anteriormente estos
efectos colaterales que no ha sido una
imagen positiva no han creado
efectos positivos en la sociedad al
contrario ha sido negativo 1 en la
anorexia segundo en la bolivia y la
tercera que tristemente aqui en mexico
en el último año el 50% de las personas
bueno en un 50% aumentaron las cirugías
plásticas qué quiere decir esto que no
nos aceptamos como personas no nos
queremos no tenemos autoestima y con
esto nos lleva un poquito a ser
ignorantes y qué pasa con ignorancia la
ignorancia lleva posteriormente a la
discriminación
y esto no nos lleva a que los roles
establecidos desde un inicio y media
trabajan desde un inicio porque no
sabemos de dónde provienen de dónde
vienen estos estereotipos culturales y
sociales hay roles que queremos sentir
lo que cumplir como que la mamá de debe
ser la amorosa dama de casa una dama
que se tiene que portar bien como debes
hablar como debes vestirte como te debes
de comportar inclusive siempre estuvimos
a expensas del hombre mucho menos voy a
hablar de aquellas personas que tienen
gustos diferentes por qué por qué de
inmoral ante la sociedad entonces vamos
a ver un poquito unas imágenes no de la
publicidad
entre los 40 y los 60 donde claramente
se ve esta discriminación de que habla
de que es esta discriminación por
ejemplo en este caso son niños de color
que claramente te decían si usas este
producto te vas a ir blanqueando que
quiere decir que un niño este grito no
podía ser un negro blanco no hacerse un
poquito más blanco por otro lado no está
está de notación de estos dos niños
diferentes un afroamericano un
anglosajón que le dice eres negrito está
sucio porque no te la vamos con este
jabón no para que para hacerte blanco
este que bueno amigos bastante
denigrante no te dice mantener su lugar
donde pertenece a quien abajo a los pies
del hombre no por decirlo de una manera
por otro lado este es un mundo de
hombres si demuestra lo demuestra le a
ella donde deben ser qué rol debe de
cumplir
algo muy interesante es de que la
publicidad así como la mercadotecnia ha
avanzado estos segmentos se están
especializando estos grupos se han hecho
grupos más pequeños grupos más pequeños
donde estas características ya son
homogéneas ahí me di cuenta que no era
tan rara después del todo qué quiere
decir ya tenía un lugar esto se conoce
como nicho de mercado el nicho de
mercado lo que hace es de que el grupo
estas personas y les da su preferencia
de de sus gustos de sus peculiaridades
un ejemplo y un ejemplo muy burdo son
los viejitos no las personas adultas
mayores que siempre han sido una parte
fundamental de nuestra sociedad pero que
no se les toman en cuenta muchos mismos
hacerles publicidad para ellos ahora ya
sean productos para ellos que satisfagan
sus necesidades y aún así los publicitan
para que se den a conocer
y la publicidad no ha avanzado lo que se
conoce como tendencia publicitaria
vamos a ver lo entrecomillado como si
fuera una moda pero realmente no es una
moda es investigar realmente lo que se
quiere realmente lo que necesitamos lo
que lo que la gente está sintiendo por
decirlo de una manera ahí nos llevan no
a la construcción de una imagen de una
marca que no busca la publicidad nada
más para que lo compre sino para decirte
yo como marca entiendo entiendo que eres
viejito y que quieres estas cosas si
quieres ahora te voy a hacer estas cosas
y que y que te sientes a gusto de alguna
otra manera
[Música]
hablando un poquito no queda la
segmentación estas necesidades o se
llame sentí en algún lugar ya no me
sentía fuera del lugar
últimamente en los últimos años en los
últimos diez años ha habido una
renovación un cambio dramático drástico
bastante agresivo sobre sobre la
publicidad nuestras campañas
publicitarias hablando de esta
específicamente es una publicidad de una
compañía de higiene personal y en sus
imágenes maneja todos los tipos de
cuerpo de mujer que quiere decir desde
la rellenita de verdad chaparrita alta
no todas estas diferencias pagamos la
belleza real y que era más esto de
notando que cada mujer como es es única
y no tienes que ser la perfección como
hasta la fecha se había marcado otra y
es esta muñeca por la cual yo adoraba yo
crecí jugando
la muñeca yo quería ser esa muñeca
empezó a hacer productos con
características reales qué quiere decir
ahora las niñas van a poderse
identificar con una muñeca ya no
necesita decir es simplemente una muñeca
por otro lado y está esta campaña de mis
favoritas que venden riñas de matrimonio
y que más tradicional que un matrimonio
pero que hicieron vamos a incluir todas
estas minorías de todas estas
diferencias las vamos a incluir en
imagen publicitaria para que para que se
marquen para que se sepa que se están
tomando en cuenta en este caso esta
marca y son una campaña no nada más
manejando a la mujer y al hombre el
matrimonio sino también una pareja
homosexual una pareja gay no que es que
el amor es simplemente
aquí por ejemplo de esta misma campaña
se ve claramente una chica afroamericana
con un chico anglosajón o abajo aunque
son la pareja también la misma pareja
indígena
a otra marca de gafas de sol
estadounidense muy bien posicionada que
nosotros conocemos yo creo que la
mayoría nos gustaría tener unos de sus
lentes diría eso eslogan de wright y que
quiere decir nunca te escondas porque
denotando a la pareja gay
no vamos a dejar un lado a una compañía
estadounidense es una asociación que
trabaja con puras personas de
capacidades diferentes que hace está
esta publicidad quita los maniquís
perfectos porque ese eslogan dice por
qué quién es perfecto nadie somos
perfecto
entonces quitan estos maniquíes de la
perfección física para poner personas
con sus moldes tomaron nuestras medidas
de ellos hicieron maniquís con sus
moldes muchas personas lo criticaron
dijeron que era muy agresiva que era muy
discriminatoria por decirlo de una
manera y no simplemente los estuvieron
incluyendo somos un parte activa de
nuestra sociedad
aquí se ve poquito no como se ve la
diferencia o como tomaron a la figura de
esta persona para generar su molde o su
maniquí
esto nos lleva a lo que es la publicidad
social y la publicidad social a hablar a
cosas interesantes no nada más de estos
cambios de estas tendencias sino lo que
busca es concientizar y que queremos
concientizar de esas diferencias de
estas personas que son diferentes las
minorías no por decirlo las personas de
color las mujeres los niños los viejitos
las personas que no trabajan que tienen
alguna necesidad y está publicidad ya no
nada más quiere vender una base
comercial sino que buscan es de que
nosotros entendamos la naturaleza de las
personas concientizar que la palabra
clave en los valores que en un momento
determinado yo siento que se perdieron
en el camino y que de una u otra manera
los estamos reactivando entonces qué es
lo que pasa y a la mujer que es lo que
más me gusta no tiene un empoderamiento
y no me malinterpreten no es el
feminista simplemente ese está denotando
se está utilizando estas características
las habilidades que tiene como
qué quiere decir la mujer ya no va a
estar esperando todo el tiempo en casa
puede ser una mamá trabajadora y se le
va a respetar puede ser una mujer que
decida yo me voy a casar pero yo me voy
a empezar con mi profesión o puede ser
también una mujer que diga tengo 35 y
quiero casarme y no se va a sentir
quedada como antes se lo hubiera podido
criticar no se diga no en las personas
de color que tienen claramente un lugar
en la sociedad no se dirían los deportes
también a la sociedad del g20 que digo
es muy interesante porque ya están
dejando el closet atrás ya están siendo
aceptados y por ende no a aquellas
personas con discapacidades diferentes
que lejos de ver como fenómenos que los
estamos viendo como seres humanismo como
personas activas entonces que nos lleva
todo esto que a dónde vamos con todo
esto
la niña como yo en su momento en la
secundaria ya no se va a sentir rezagado
ya tiene un lugar no nada más en la
sociedad el lugar en la mercadotecnia y
ya tiene un lugar en la publicidad que
quiere decir que la ropa ya les va a
quedar a su medida ya va a tener su
gusto y yo hago de convivir con las
personas que quieran a méxico
desafortunadamente tiene un baúl todavía
vivimos en un baúl lleno de prejuicios
en los cuales está basado en el
materialismo no ser completamente
materialista y ser superficial entonces
tenemos que buscar cambiarlos si estas
disciplinas cambiaron cambiaron para
poder a ir avanzando ser incluyentes
porque no hacerlos nosotros porque no
hace algo que no es como mexicanos sino
solo también como humanos una de las
cosas interesantes es de que tenemos que
conocer estos paradigmas hay que romper
los estos seres estereotipos hay que
agarrar
y tirarlos a la basura hay que tener
inclusión hay que a tratar de informar a
todas las personas conocer y tener el
conocimiento tener la información porque
a través del conocimiento concientizamos
que hay diferencias y que somos
diferentes y si somos diferentes por
ende vamos a respetar que es lo más
importante respetar estas diferencias y
como somos respetuosos vamos a incluir
no nos vamos a hacer una sociedad
incluyente
con estos hierro y hoy me gustaría que
reflexionarán un poquito
que dice los grandes progresos de la
historia fueron impulsados por personas
que en su tiempo fueron considerado
demasiado diferentes al vencimiento de
su época